hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu der
heutigen folge minecraft galaxy part 18
das ganze ihr seht ihr schon die folge
ist nicht so lang wie sonst irgendwie 15
minuten oder irgendwie sowas so um den
dreh sondern sie geht wahrscheinlich nur
ein paar zehn minuten ich denke ich habe
das ganze dorf drei minuten oder vier
minuten runter gespielt ganz einfach aus
dem grund weil dieser folge habe ich
vergessen eine tonspur aufzunehmen
nachfolge sitzen hab ich mir gedacht ich
stieß man einfach auf der weltkarte
folgende auf den kurs von pc weg gehabt
etwas zu trinken wollte hab gedacht ich
muss noch eine folge aufnehmen
hab dann alles gestartet außer meinem
tonaufnahme programm für meine stimme
und das habe ich dementsprechend
vergessen
ihr seht das ganze gerade im
schnelligkeit im hintergrund abgespielt
und gleich betty denn ich hier gerade
aufhören zu reden
ihr seht auch jedem eine facetime ist da
und alles aber mein base camp kein ton
auf neu sind ist alles richtig blöd
gewesen wäre euch gedacht ich spiele ja
waren schnell form ab und sage euch ganz
kurz was ich gemacht habe und zwar habe
ich ich weiß ich habe schon gesehen hat
jetzt gerade oder nicht aber ich sag mal
einfach ganz gefasst gemacht habe ich
habe beiden bäume abgebaut damit ich all
diese kleinen spalt planes machen kann
aus den ich aber einen boden und dach
mache und die wollte ich dann halt in
mein haus weiter baue ich mein haus noch
ein bisschen weiter gebaut habe eine
stolze gemacht für meinen wintergarten
da wo man nicht von einem wintergarten
auf eine stellte gemacht für mein zimmer
wo mein bett drin steht und ich habe ein
neues zimmer gebaut genau gegenüber von
meinem bett zimmer was genauso auf der
anderen seite ist wo ich dann als plan
was ich euch gesagt habe die fläche voll
machen möchte mit glas so dass ich quasi
nach unten gucken kann und außen rum das
ganze mit zäunen das hab ich also ein
bisschen macht habt ja die ganze zeit
überlegt wie ich das machen kann damit
cool aussieht
ich habe sehr lange darüber nachgedacht
die ganze folge gingen am ende 13
minuten weil ich die kürzer halten
wollte weil ich nicht schon wieder
beziehen wollte und jetzt ist erstmal
komplett weg ich denke dass ich durch
diese drei minuten folge das ganze
irgendwie so ein bisschen wieder
ausgleichen konnte dass die letzten mal
über zu gehabt das tut mir leid ich fans
trotzdem cool wenn ihr den ganzen
dislike
wenn ihr den ganzen discs mit einem like
dagegen drückt also wenn ihr das video
positiv bewertet dass er super toll und
sonst würde ich sagen ich jetzt noch
viel spaß bei den letzten paar
sekündchen münchen dieses videos tut mir
noch mal sehr sehr sorry aber ich kann
also nichts mehr dran ändern und sonst
viel spaß